in what is very quickly becoming one of
the major stories of 2016 former
producer Louis will be calling into the
bonus show today I'm sorry no that's
true but what it the actual big story is
that we have now learned according to a
number of American intelligence agencies
adding to the story from earlier this
week that Russian President Vladimir
Putin a former KGB agent was personally
involved in the Russian hacking meant to
hurt Hillary Clinton in her campaign
against Donald Trump Russian involvement
in the election of Donald Trump uh uh
has become now a fundamental turning
point I would argue in terms of the
concept of sovereign American elections
US intelligence officials have a quote
high level of confidence that Putin was
personally involved in the hacking that
took place two senior US officials with
direct access to the information say
that the new intelligence shows that
Putin was personally directing how the
hacked material should be leaked and how
the hacked material should be used and
this comes from diplomatic sources and
spies working for American allies
according to American officials and
here's the most revealing part this
seems to have started not because
Vladimir Putin wanted Donald Trump to
win per se but because of light of your
Putin so-called vendetta against Hillary
Clinton and then it reportedly turned
into an effort to just more generally
show how corrupt American politics is
and quote split off key American allies
by creating the image that other
countries couldn't depend on the u.s. to
be a credible global global leader
anymore it succeeded congratulations to
Vladimir Putin who Mitt Romney said in
26 2012 Russia and Putin the greatest
geopolitical foe of the United States as
we've been talking about for a long time
now we talk Pat about who is going to be
the leader of the free world when
President Trump is president of the u.s.
it's not going to be Trump and Russia
has successfully undermine the a
dia of the US as a credible global
leader with Donald Trump they they
succeed excuse me they succeeded who who
thought that Mitt Romney we would be
right on that point that Russia would be
the greatest geopolitical threat it
turns out that the election of Donald
Trump has verified that ultimately the
CIA did say by the end of this little
project for Vladimir Putin they did
proactively want to elect Trump but
that's not how it started it started
just as hurting Hillary and we now know
this goes way further than intelligence
suggested back in October the US with
solid information time Putin to the
operation this is major major major this
is one of the most successful campaigns
that we have ever seen in the history of
the United States to meddle in American
elections by a foreign power now first
of all at a sort of micro level do Trump
supporters realize how embarrassing it
is that their guy is a puppet that was
helped by a foreign power called our
greatest geopolitical foe just four
years ago one of my cousins made a good
point about this on Facebook saying you
know the US has actually been
interfering with elections in other
parts of the world for a very long time
not that many people in the u.s. scared
that we were influencing other countries
elections so maybe they won't care that
another country influenced hours I don't
know well this is the interesting
republican talking point going around
now that no voter was actually
influenced by what the kremlin had to
say right and what russia wanted to be
the outcome of the election yeah but it
yet go step further than that is what
they hacked that would give a false
impression of Hillary Clinton and cause
them to change their mind in vote for
Donald Trump yeah on Twitter I've got
all these trumpets saying David I voted
for Trump and it had nothing to do with
what Putin said this isn't about what
Putin said right Trump won by 58
thousand votes across three key states
while losing hugely in the popular vote
and it's abundantly clear that were it
not for this coordinated smear campaign
by the President of Russia a lifelong
KGB agent that Donald Trump would be
very unlikely to have won that election
and conservatives talk about American
sovereignty even if the guy that bamboo
willed you into voting for him one and
you like that he won in part because of
another country's operations for their
own fun and games and American
sovereignty over our own elections has
been completely compromised this will be
written about in history books this is
historic Vladimir Putin's involvement
here uh to to get a clueless reality
show buffoon elected who is now
appointing Russia friendly business
buddies to run the country and will be
getting to decide on Supreme Court
justices Putin and his buddies are
probably laughing hysterically every day
aren't they Pat I mean they must just be
yucking it up over there yeah they're
very happy with the outcome so it seems
they got a country around 325 million
people to elect an authoritarian strong
man who has no idea what he's doing in
Vladimir Putin we know has wanted to be
seen as a powerful uh of force in the
world and I think that he has achieved
that here Russian hacking has changed
the direction of the United States and I
want to go further for a second I don't
believe for a second the Donald Trump
didn't know about this I'm not saying
that Donald Trump was coordinating with
Russia but we can't really believe Pat
that Paul Manafort working for Trump
direct connections to the Kremlin uh
prior attempts at business dealings with
Russia Trump connections to Russian
billionaires etcetera it's very hard for
me to believe that Trump was completely
in the dark about what Russia was doing
and now you can even take a look at his
cabinet picks because his choice for
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson has a
long history with dealing with aamir
Putin another story line here is all of
a sudden Republicans don't think
Russia's that bad right nothing material
has changed since in 2012 Romney said
Russia's our biggest geopolitical foe
Republicans didn't really argue against
that then nothing has materially changed
except for the fact that now we have
that country that was our greatest
geopolitical foe having acted to help
Donald Trump win remember when Trump
during the campaign said the world is
laughing at us turns out he was right
but it has nothing at all to do with
President Obama